hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host john
carroll very often here on the podcast
we talk about the laws of physics right
both what they are and what they might
be you know we don't have all of the
laws of physics completely settled yet
so one of the ongoing things that
physicists try to do is suggest
different kinds of laws of physics but
there's different kinds and different
kinds there are specific laws of physics
like the standard model of particle
physics is a very very specific set of
laws or einstein's theory of general
relativity is a specific set of laws but
then there are broader frameworks within
which we can think about proposing laws
the obvious ones would be quantum
mechanics is a broad framework classical
mechanics is also a broad framework but
even those two broad frameworks of
classical and quantum mechanics they
share a certain underlying paradigm what
in other contexts i've called the
laplacian paradigm for doing physics and
the laplacian paradigm is basically
you give me the state of a system
either now or in the far past as initial
conditions there's something we call the
state of the system that has all the
information you need and then there are
dynamical laws the dynamical laws say
starting from that state where does the
system evolve to and you can evolve it
forward in time or if the theory is
reversible both forward and backward in
time if you like
and that kind of paradigm is broader
even than the ideas the frameworks of
classical mechanics and quantum
mechanics so
what if that paradigm isn't right
what if it's not the best way to think
about physics in either some contexts or
even all contexts that's the suggestion
made by something called constructor
theory
which was first proposed by david
deutsch at oxford and has been picked up
by some people most notably by today's
guest kiara marletto who is both a
collaborator of deutsches and also has
moved the field forward herself and with
other collaborators quite a bit so the
idea of constructor theory very very
roughly you'll hear more about it later
is that rather than
being given conditions for the system
and how they evolve you tell me the
complete set of things that can be done
and things that cannot be done
within the laws of physics whatever they
are
and somehow the set of things that can
happen and cannot happen so factual and
counterfactual possibilities um are
enough to either hopefully maybe ideally
completely tell you the laws of physics
or at least shed some explanatory light
on what actually happens in the world
and this is potentially very interesting
you know as we'll talk near the end of
the podcast uh chiara has come up with
some
ways to use this perspective to propose
things you might not have proposed by
doing physics the more conventional way
like possible experimental tests of
quantum gravity
but also a completely new perspective
says that you change what you think of
are the interesting and relevant puzzles
and problems in your field potentially
you think about connections for example
between fundamental physics and emergent
higher levels in different ways
so it's clear why you might want to do
something like this it's very very
ambitious you know you're trying to do
big things it also is hopefully clear
what the drawbacks of something like
this is
the more ambitious you are the harder it
is to get things right you know i mean
the laplacian paradigm has been around
for a lot of years it was implicit in
the work of galileo and newton and
pierre simone laplace circa the year
1800
put it down uh quite explicitly so
that's a long track record of success
to try to start with physics on a
completely different footing
it's hard because you'll probably fail
right most ways of doing physics are
going to be wrong and you have some
success in the current system so why not
just stick with that and try to improve
it but it's good that some people try to
jump out of the current way of doing
things and look at things from a brand
new angle
the burden on them is to sort of come up
with some useful
signposts along the way that correspond
to real advances that we can all agree
on or solving some puzzle so
i will try to um or rather we because i
really don't understand this stuff very
well we i and kiara will try to uh
explain what constructor theory is why
it might be useful why it has things to
say not about just fundamental physics
like quantum gravity and quantum
mechanics itself but also real world
stuff uh heat engines thermodynamics
the physics of life and biology and so
forth so i think it's a one of these
fascinating conversations it goes a lot
of places i will remind you as i
occasionally do that you can support the
mindscape podcast on patreon if you go
to patreon.com
sean m carroll you can uh
post a little uh pledge rather a little
donation once per episode
a dollar or a euro or even more if you'd
like to do that mostly i think the
reason to do this is just to express
appreciation but you also get ad-free
versions of the podcast
and once a month as you know i do ask me
anything episodes and it's the patreon
supporters that get to
ask the questions that are answered on
the ask me anything episodes but mostly
it's a little community of people who
like the mindscape podcast and support
it and for whom i am extremely grateful
it really uh helps keep me going podcast
wise which i hope everyone is enjoying
so with that let's uh let kiara take
over and expand our minds a little bit
let's go
[Music]
welcome to the winescape podcast
great to be here
so one thing that strikes me about what
you're trying to do is it's super
ambitious right you're sort of rewriting
the rules for how physics should be done
so before we get into the actual ways in
which you're doing that let me just ask
the
sort of uh more personal question i mean
if one of my graduate students said yeah
i'm gonna work on
completely changing the way that we do
physics i would say don't do that or at
least don't do that until you're a
little bit older right you know it's
good to be ambitious but it's also hard
to get things right when you're that
ambitious right from the start so i mean
how do you how do you think about that
do you do you think well
you know screw it i'm just gonna be
ambitious and we'll see what happens or
is it a matter of going back and forth
between being super ambitious and being
more down to earth
yes so i think the
so as i said
initially when i um
when i started working on this this was
during my phd in oxford
and uh what happened is that i so
attended this very interesting talk that
david deutsch gave on um sketching or
outlining what
uh this program
uh of constructor theory
um
was about and how uh he envisaged this
as being like a generalization of the
quantum theory of computation
and so in a way because my phd was on
the quantum zero computation um
i was uh very intrigued by this this
idea that there could be something more
something beyond that
um and
since then
my
main question the thing that interested
me
beside this of course bold vision of
reformulating laws of physics in
different way and so on
was um is there a way that we can find
problems that are currently open and
tractable
that we can address with this approach
and so so in a sense my
my um
focus uh so far has been to find these
problems and solve them
in a way that this uh is in a way of
convincing my own my own self that is
actually um
a worthwhile good uh working approach
and i'm completely open to the fact that
this may not work
um to the degree that that in a way the
the whole program uh hopes
but i think so far the results are uh
promising enough that that kind of they
entice me to work more on it
and more broadly i think there's one
more point i wanted to make i think in
general any work in foundational physics
is
about
you know working out these bold
questions so even though
um yes yep you know such a the kind of
um
advice to students is to try to find
tractable problems um i think uh
it's it's the case that that what
physics is about is to address these
questions and so in that sense i don't
see what i'm doing as a particularly
um unusual or or
different thing from what
you know all physicists that are
interested in foundations are really
doing
it's just one of the various things that
we're trying to you know move a step
forward and
try to find new ways of solving these
open problems yeah that sounds perfectly
fair to me but i have noticed uh in my
own
uh writing papers giving talks and
getting responses to them that there's
always a difficulty when
you have to both convince the audience
that there exists a problem and that
you're making progress solving it right
like everyone has a list of actual
existing problems in their head and if
you say you're solving those like why is
there more matter than anti-matter
people go oh yes that's a good problem
to be working on but uh
is this the situation you find yourself
in where you have to convince people
that there is an issue to be addressed
or are people more or less sympathetic
to that well depends on the particular
kind of
problem
i think i do
recall um having to to elaborate on uh
you know
why
you know there is a problem with the
quantum theory of computation itself
um so i think this is because
most
people who are currently working in the
field are
somewhat focused on the technological
developments that stem from the field
but they are not perhaps um focusing on
the
more foundational aspect that are
actually the ones um
you know
the reasons why the the quantum theory
computation in a way came about in the
first place
um and so in that sense yes sometimes
you have to uh you know point out that
there are these new problems but on in
broad attempts i think some of the other
issues i've been working on which have
to do with this um issue of
making predictions in cases where the
dynamical laws that we have either fail
or we don't quite know which particular
dynamical law we could apply
um this is a problem that's recognized
by by most people who work in
foundations of physics in the sense that
you know both in the uh from an example
it's the quantum gravity community where
of course this is a this is a known
issue um and likewise
problems of the foundation of
thermodynamics have some uh kind of open
problems that i don't have to argue
about because they're already somehow um
understood
so yeah i think it's um
um the the most challenging thing i've
found myself
uh
tackling so far is really the
uh
so showing that there is a
um kind of advantage in appealing to
these principles that constructive
theory has
um
which can
lead us to
somehow supplement uh the
dynamical laws as we currently know them
and so in that sense this is um
this is more like a kind of challenging
uh finding
specific problems where this approach
makes a difference
uh rather than in explaining why the
problems are important which i think in
a way it's understood at least in the
foundational community
right and so i i i'm getting the
impression that this grew out of
thinking about quantum mechanics quantum
foundations and quantum computation and
information in particular so that's a
pretty easy sell these days everyone
agrees that uh quantum computing is
something interesting so it may be if
you uh are presenting a framework that
will help us understand that that's a
that's a relatively tangible thing that
people can hold on to yes and i think uh
perhaps the the less um
less kind of uh
widely known thing is that
uh when you look at the quantum theory
computation
uh so you you know you open you open a
textbook where
they are proving some theorems about
channel capacity or other things
most of what's proven there is
rooted
completely in the formalism of quantum
theory of non-relativistic quantum
mechanics really and um
this is um a plus of course in the sense
that uh it's great that we can prove
these theorems but somehow if you look
at it from a pure from a purist point of
view um
from from the point of view of a
person who's interested in information
theory
you would consider this as a slight
deficiency in fact an important
deficiency i would say of the of the
approach because
as a theory of information
if you compare it to say turing's theory
of classical information it really
relies a lot on the formalism of
particular theory which
we know
will somehow have to be modified
um
one way or another by the next kind of
dynamical law that will merge quantum
zero and gr and general relativity
so um in that sense i think the
one of the aims of this program that i'm
kind of uh developing
is to find a way of emancipating these
results from
the specific details of quantum theory
while still retaining all of the
information theoretic
reach of the results themselves
so in a way you know still being able to
talk about things like entanglement and
superpositions and um
you know exponential speed up due to
quantum effects
without there being a specific
formalism or
which is the one of
the formalism quantum theory um so so
this is one way in which the theore
computation needs to be generalized um
and it's quite important i think because
so in a way we haven't quite completed
the program of um
formulating the quantum theory of
computation in this more general way and
constructor theory is
attempting this generalization
yeah i want to get to the details of
constructor theory but you keep saying
interesting things that i that i need to
follow up on then the interesting things
you just said was
the possibility or the prospect that
standard quantum theory itself might
need to be modified in some way um of
course that's always a possibility but
i and i think a lot of other physicists
would say you know there's no evidence
that we need that kind of thing
except maybe if you say that the fact
that we haven't quantized gravity yet
should should make us skeptical but you
seem more open to the fact that quantum
theory itself is going to not be
uh
up to the task of describing physics in
the years to come
yeah i think there are a number of
reasons why why i think this um so on
the one hand there is what you said uh
there is the fact that
we have a number of
very um
well-crafted
um proposals for quantum gravity
um both in the perturbative regime
regime and and
regime and so on um but
there is no um somehow consensus on
which one of these is the right one and
there are some conceptual issues with
with some of them and
difficulty in finding
obvious predictions that stem out of
them and so on so in that sense i think
in the absence of
this one candidate
um it's quite
uh important i think to emancipate the
results that we have about the
universality of computation and um there
is other things that pertain to the
quantum zero computation from the
specific formal aspects of quantum
theory because um
some of them may stay and some of them
may not stay in the future uh but
whatever happens i think my bet is that
the information theoretic structure of
quantum theory will
be maintained so things like the quantum
multiverse
the the idea that
the kind of quantum computing mechanism
will still be viable
and the possibility of proving that the
universal quantum computer is
has modes of computation that are more
general than those accessible to a
classical universal computer all these
things will still be
true
and we need a way of expressing them
without necessarily rooting them into
quantum theory the other reason why i
think quantum theory is
somewhat problematic or has some
um
you know some kind of things that are
not so satisfactory about it
um is that
there is this uh field which is called
quantum field theory which is um
something that we effectively use
whenever we have to make a perform a
calculation uh to perform some kind of
predictive uh statement about what
happens in laboratory and so on so in
that sense
you know it's it's a it's a very
successful thing
formalism
but
you know
quantum field theory itself was at least
conceived by those who proposed it
um especially in regard to the theory of
electromagnetism um
a kind of work in progress so it wasn't
really supposed to stay as a fundamental
theory of nature
so
and it has issues so it has various
issues mathematical issues and
it also has conceptual issues
to do with um continuum and and things
of that kind
um
so in in a way i also find that
not such a
satisfactory theoretical device
from the foundational point of view of
course it's very successful and you know
it's it's great that we can use it to
make predictions about things that we um
we can test right now and so on but the
question is well you know we need a
better theory um and so in all these
cases i'd like
to be able to um
build a more uh
robust
foundation for the edifice of quantum
tier computation so that it will survive
no matter what the new
dynamical law will be
there are a few higher stakes activities
that a company can do than to hire new
people you don't have that many jobs you
need to find the right people and
indeed.com is here to help you out
indeed is the job site that makes hiring
incredibly simple you can attract you
can interview and you can hire all on
the same web page indeed's hiring tools
help you cut through the noise to hire
faster and smarter and indeed instant
match provides a list of quality
candidates whose resumes are on indeed
the moment you post a sponsored job
according to talent nest indeed delivers
four times more hires than all other job
sites combined so you can join the more
than 3 million businesses worldwide that
use indeed to hire great talent fast
get started right now with a 75 dollar
sponsor job credit to upgrade your job
post at indeed.com
mindscape get a 75 credit at indeed.com
mindscape that's
indeed.com mindscape offer valid through
october 31 terms and conditions
apply okay that that is a good set of
motivations so now that we're motivated
uh i mean maybe i want to ask about what
exactly constructor theory says but is
it first helpful to compare it to the
standard paradigm if we have people
listening in the audiences who are not
professional physicists um uh what what
is it about the standard way of doing
physics that is there
that you're uh considering either
altering or presenting an alternative to
yeah so um first let me
just say one thing that is perhaps
slightly related to the the formal
question but it kind of prepares the
answer to this one that so the name
constructor theory
might
um make the you know
people wonder why constructed what what
is that
um so i think the um
um
i think for neumann so this is a a term
that was coined by for neumann
um so
he was wondering
um whether there could be a more general
device um that can somehow supplement
the notion of a computer
so he
he was
trying to find ways of saying that
the way in which turing had devised its
universal computer
um
was um
too limited and so in a way while a
universal fury machine can simulate
anything that is permitted by the
dynamical model on which it runs
it may not be able to perform
all the
physically allowed transformations
not just computations so more general
transformations and the classic example
that for neumann gave in one of his
brilliant lectures in the 50s was that
there is this task which is the task of
self-reproduction which of course cells
can
implement very easily
um
now this is a task that requires the
device in question to create a replica
of itself
and while a universal turing machine can
simulate in its workspace um you know an
ecosystem with cells uh self-reproducing
and undergoing natural selection and so
on
it cannot itself uh be programmed to
create a replica um of itself so that's
that's one you know slight kind of
drawback of turing's uh construction
it's very unfortunate i can kind of
create a replica of my computer just by
programming it in a suitable way
um but um so so in that sense phenomenon
thought we need to treat more general
programmable machines
and constructors that's the term he
coined
were
precisely
used to kind of
label this more general class of
programming machines which include
programmable computers but also this
more universal set of
objects that can perform
general physical transformations not
just computations
and the universal constructor is
a machine that can
perform any
transformation that's physically allowed
so it's a kind of ultimate
generalization of turing's
universal machine the reason why
we use the term constructor is because
the
key
new step in constructor theory is that
we would like to focus
laws of physics and the fundamental laws
of physics
not just on
um
what traditionally is considered to be
the most fundamental way of formulating
levels of physics which is to use a
dynamical law with some boundary
condition or initial condition however
you want to call it
but we'd like to enlarge the set of
fundamental statements
to include statements about
what physical transformations are
impossible and what are possible and
also why
and i think when we talk about
a possible transformation
uh
there is where the
notion of constructor is hidden
because
the statement that the transformation is
possible
means that
given a set of laws of physics
the performing that task
to the transformation
to um arbitrarily high accuracy
with a device that works like a
constructor so it can perform the task
and work in a cycle so it retains the
ability of causing it again
so
this
phenomenon that leads to the task to
being performed by this constructor
is
allowed to arbitrarily high accuracy
that's what possible
means
and the fact that the task is impossible
on the other hand means that there is a
fundamental limitation to how well you
can
you know approximate the behavior of a
constructor for a given transformation
and the constructor is in this case an
even more general um notion than the one
that was proposed by um
for neumann because it's really any
system
that
can enact enable a transformation on a
different system
and then um
retain the ability of causing it again
so it's in a way it's something that can
work in a cycle so you can think of it
as a generalization of things like um
enzymes or
thermal engines or computers
and of course it can be programmed as
well and so on but i think it doesn't
have to be
programmable and um
in a way the fact that it works in a
cycle allows you to remove it
from
the statement about
the law of physics and uh the law of
physics are just then about
uh what's possible what's impossible
without having to deal with the
complexity of it of each particular
constructor
uh so that's that's perhaps the key
uh step that distinguishes this approach
from the traditional
approach so these statements are
supposed to be now the most fundamental
statements and things like dynamical
laws and boundary conditions should be
explained in terms of them
so so that's the fundamental switch that
you need to um
take when you when you try to formulate
the laws in in this way that we are
proposing
so good so i think this is actually
helpful to me anyway i hope to the rest
of the audience but uh so to restate
that yeah the the
bringing up von neumann is very very
helpful here so
um
can i think about it as saying that the
point that touring made was that
regardless of any individual computer
you might build i can imagine
this universal computer and asking what
it can and cannot do sheds light on the
very idea of computation in the limits
of that in the physical world
and likewise
with von neumann's constructors you and
david deutsch and your
collaborators are saying that if we knew
uh the whole set of
things that could or could not be
performed the whole set of tasks that
could or could not be performed by
the universal constructor or or
individual constructors that would be
equivalent to what most physicists think
of as knowing the full laws of physics
is that the idea
yes indeed
and i think it would be
that's a very nice way of putting it um
and the so so here there are a few
really exciting insights
the first insight is what you said that
uh it's already implicit in the quantum
theory computation
that by
studying limitations of programmable
machines which
seem to be emergent and
you know they're supposed to be
something that isn't really at the
foundations of physics according to the
traditional way of looking physics
you can actually understand
better the foundations of a very
deep uh theory which in the case of
quantum theory computation is quantum
theory and in the case of constructive
theory we are hoping um
can be a more general set of laws uh
dynamical laws that include quantum
theory but possibly
its successors and and so on
um
and the other
insight is that
by
switching to the study of these
statements about possible impossible
transformations
you are um
liberating you are trying to you know
you you manage to escape this set of um
philosophically problematic um issues
that
the traditional conception of physics
runs into
for example
the fact that
we put a lot of emphasis in the
traditional way of doing physics on
dynamical laws
but somehow we always have
and um
you you kind of have
written very eloquently about this that
we always have this issue of um
you know setting the theory of what are
the boundaries what are the initial
supplementary conditions for these laws
and um this is an issue that is still
open in a sense because there are very
many theories that are proposed about
cosmology and also there are issues
about how to test them um and the you
know the explanatory statements they
make
are um
somehow uh perhaps less um established
than uh those you can make with with the
purely you know set the pure set of
dynamical laws
and by appealing to this additional set
of principles uh we are
um trying also to explain to provide a
kind of explanatory foundation for
uh theory of of cosmology so in a sense
we are trying to um
solve this issue of okay we've got the
dynamical laws now we have to fix
initial conditions and um
theories about those seem to be a bit
arbitrary or or hard to pin down we want
general principles that can help us
understanding also
what those theories could be
so in that sense um this is an
additional bonus that comes from uh
expanding the set of statements that you
take as fundamental in your
physical picture of the universe
yeah i mean that would be great if we
shed some light on the problem that
from the traditional point of view is
what are the initial conditions for the
universe right and it's very often true
that if you change perspectives
even if the
formalism that you invent is completely
equivalent problems that seemed hard in
the original formalism become more
illuminated and even easy in the new
formalism so is your is constructor
theory supposed to be
in principle equivalent to the standard
way of having initial conditions plus
dynamical laws or do you think that it's
possible the laws of physics ultimately
just can't be expressed in terms of
initial conditions and dynamical laws
and constructor theory will give you
something better bigger different than
that
so this is something that
will become clear in the future so we
don't have
results yet that can help us
understand which one of these two
options
is the true one
but the
the hope is that
this approach can
enlarge the set of things we can say
about the universe so in a way um
dynamical laws and in initial conditions
if this approach works
um would still be true in some
approximate domain in a way
but they would be like emerging
consequences of these deeper principles
um and i think you can
understand perhaps in what sense this
could be true by
uh considering um a principle that uh
you know one of the principles that is
is most well known in in a sense in
physics which is this
principle of conservation of energy
which i know also you're quite
interested in
so the
if you take the principle conservation
of energy as
a statement about universe about the
universe you can you can perhaps think
of it in two different ways so one is
to say well i have this particular set
of dynamical laws and i've got
a quantity that i call energy or even a
more general quantity doesn't have to be
energy and then i can derive by using
the symmetries of these laws that
actually this quantity is conserved so
it's one way of understanding what the
law says
but there is a different way of thinking
about it which is um to say that
the law says that in all
you know true laws of nature
those that we already know and those
that we may actually come up with in the
future
um
there must be a quantity called
something energy or more general
quantity that has to be conserved
now this
lattice statement if you consider it is
more general than the former in the
sense that the former statement is
always particular to a specific
formalism of a particular dynamical law
and
it doesn't really take a view on what
we might want to
conjecture tomorrow about you know a
better dynamical law but the latter
statement really is like a kind of
draconian constraint on
uh
any law that we might uh come up with in
the future really has to conform to this
idea that the task of
creating energy out of no energy is
really impossible and so in this latter
statement you could say
any particular symmetry of a particular
dynamical law that happens to conform to
this principle is
in a way explainable in terms of this
more
general way of formulating the
conservation law in question
and so this is the sense in which we
expect that these principles of
constructor theory
should play a role in
deriving or explaining
features of dynamics in a deeper way
than just saying well the dynamics is
like this there are these symmetries and
we expect these things to be conserved
um so so that's the
that's somehow the switching perspective
and that's why we expect
that constructive theory statements
should be somehow more general than any
particular statement you can make within
a specific law of motion that you happen
to know
okay i think uh this is all very helpful
but maybe
i'm cheating because i know a little bit
because you wrote a book and i've i've
read much of the book etc but the
audience hasn't so let's bring it really
down to earth um
a traditional
paradigmatic thing that physicists do
physics problem that we explain is
uh the motion of planets around the sun
right kepler's laws kepler came up with
the laws there's ellipses and then
newton explained them using this
paradigm this old-fashioned paradigm of
dynamical equations plus initial
conditions
how would i explain kepler's laws from a
constructed theory point of view is that
even a fair question is that the kind of
thing that you would think about uh
addressing
yes i think um in a way
this is a very interesting
uh example because
um
it's specifically so this this is this
is exactly one of those cases where
you could explain the phenomenon in
question in two
different ways so one is to say well
you know
i have these laws newton's laws and i've
got some initial conditions and i know
that for certain initial conditions i
will end up having certain kinds of
trajectories for these objects and then
i can put in the values for masses and
and various other constants and find out
exactly
um
something that matches the structure of
the
of the solar system as we as we know it
right now
but there is a different way
which is to say
let's now list
all the
constraints
about
quantities that are conserved and um
things that are impossible to create out
of nothing and and so on and now you
wouldn't quite get
the
prediction
uh the quantitative prediction about how
a
particular
feature of the
orbit of a given planet
should be so you wouldn't get the
quantitative
aspects of the
dynamical predictions
but you would narrow down
the set of allowed dynamical laws and
initial conditions that are compatible
with these general constraints
and now
within these laws there would be
newton's laws but also of course
einstein's
general relativity equations
and perhaps future laws that they will
also be able to describe by taking
appropriate limits the current uh you
know structure of the solar system
and um
of course to make quantitative
predictions you would need those
dynamical laws
but to explain all of their features you
would have to appeal to these more
general statements about what's
conserved and what are the things that
you can't change and what are the
transformation you cannot or can
perform so that's that's the idea so the
um the the
bet is that
just by confining yourself to
the dynamical laws you can't express
all of the reasons why
say the solar system is the way it is
um
and most importantly you can't capture
all of the other possible dynamical laws
that you could use in order to describe
it
and so you need to somehow enlarge the
set of statements that you appeal to in
order to explain
um a certain dynamical motion that you
happen to be able to verify in your
vicinity in the universe um
and perhaps a good example here um
has also to do with uh the information
principles that you can construct in
constructor theory so in a way maybe we
can discuss this in a
maybe in the next question or a bit
later
yeah no we can be i i do want to dig
into this one a little bit more because
i i
may or may not have understood what you
said but but are you saying that knowing
all of the
principles of what can and cannot uh
happen so you know energy is conserved
angular momentum is conserved etc this
is not enough to derive kepler's laws is
that true we need something else well
you wouldn't be able to derive
the exact
uh quantitative statements about
the
for example the the the
certain geometry of a particular orbit
and the
given let's say
all the features of the uh of the sun
and of the planets and of the things
that are orbiting around the sun and so
on so in that sense the dynamical laws
were in in specific case newton's laws
are um
about
some of these predictions
and this is something that you can't get
just by stating uh
a set of
possible impossible transformations
because that is a qualitative set of set
of statements
um so in that sense i think
the
predictions you would get out of a set
of statements about possible impossible
transformations
are compatible with
newton's laws
and kepler's laws but also with other
laws that are more general and we may
not have conjectured yet
um
and also include
of course
einstein's general relativity which is a
kind of
improvement on those laws
um so so in this sense i think it's it's
not enough to just concentrate
on the statements about you know on
statements that say what transformations
are possibly impossible
to derive all the statements that you
can derive from say things like newton's
laws
um
but
the statement i'm making and we are kind
of making in general in this research
program
is that
there are things in the
reality that you can describe it with
with dynamical laws such as newtons
that can't be explained within just
newton's laws
and they therefore to have a complete
picture you need both
the dynamical law approach
supplemented with these uh more general
principles
and then we make the statement that we
believe that these more general
principles are actually uh in a way you
can think of them as more fundamental
because in a sense they are
um more general than any specific low
emotion
uh so so that these are the two logical
steps involved in
in thinking about the principles and the
relations to uh dynamical laws
okay so oh good this is i think this is
helping me out but let me let me just
check that i have not uh fooled myself
into thinking i understand what's going
on so um
in the standard picture when we have
newton's laws we can derive the fact
that energy is conserved and momentum is
conserved etc
but they seem a little bit parasitic on
the underlying dynamical laws and um
you're making the case that it would be
better to consider them as
you know at least on a
on an equal footing if not a more
fundamental footing than those dynamical
laws for for reasons of explanatory
power is that fair yes okay yes correct
and in general as i said uh once you
have derived the conservation of energy
within a specific law of motion
uh that isn't
very explanatory about
um
possible other laws of motion so in a
way in this framework where
um
you know you're considering the fact
that this low emotion may be modified
um and you want to use these principles
actually guidelines to help you out in
in guessing future laws which is
actually what we do in physics
ultimately because that's how we use
principles
um the
you know thinking of the conservation of
a certain quantity as being just
an implication of a particular law
motion isn't very helpful so in a way
this this logic i'm advocating isn't uh
that new because it's something that we
have been informally using for for quite
a bit in physics
so principles are helpful when we want
to conjecture future laws of physics
it's just here we were pointing out that
there are some phenomena um
which are described by some of these
aramaic laws that we know that
can't quite
be
exactly captured within just those laws
so you kind of need these other
additional set of statements to fully
explain them and
so conservation laws are an example
there are other examples
and yeah so i think this is kind of yeah
but what you said is exactly it so good
that's very helpful i'm just going to
keep uh hitting on this one example a
couple more times because i'm really
this is very very helpful to me and it
is uh
putting it in these concrete terms is
making me understand but um if i
understand what you said then
you know newton says that the force due
to gravity obeys an inverse square law
right the force fades away as the
inverse of the square of the distance
between the objects
i could imagine
other possible worlds in which it obeyed
an inverse cube law or something like
that and energy would still be conserved
and angular momentum would still be
conserved so what i'm guessing and
you'll correct me if i'm wrong is that
constructor theory uh is is sort of
silent on which one is right and the
full theory of the world would include
in your view both these general
principles and some specific uh addendum
that says they're they're instantiated
in the following way in the actual world
is that correct or did i go too far yes
i think this is correct
there is one interesting thought there
that one could explore and this is to do
with
um
could one then explain even the
particular scaling of a particular
dynamical law in terms of some other
counterfactual principle
which we don't perhaps yet know
um likewise
this is similar in the in the
you know there's a like similar question
let's say in quantum theory where um
we have this
certain you know
rule that
what we call the bone rule which has to
do with how to compute probabilities
from um
given say the quantum state of a given
object
and there are other assignments that
could be in principle other assignments
for computing this kind of probability
rule
um
and the question is well in this case
we're just postulating that the rule has
to be
like that and at least this is what you
do in textbook quantum mechanics um
but
so there could be more general
principles
that you can uh conjecture
uh which would then pin down the exact
uh scaling that the one rule conjectures
for the
probability law in quantum theory uh so
this is a similar question to a similar
issue to the one you pointed out um and
i think this can be said about for
example constants of nature that are
also currently unexplained in general in
even a specific dynamical law so why a
given value not another
so if the program works in the way we
expect
you could then link all of these
apparently accidental features of
laws that we currently use in order to
predict things
successfully um
to actually a more explanatory principle
that um ultimately can be expressed
about you know in terms of these
statements about what's possible and
what's impossible in
you know on a given subsystem of the
universe when you're trying to perform a
transformation on it but of course it's
a conjecture so so it's it's a kind of
work in progress proving all of this
and it's certainly true that just from
the conservation laws you can't of
course pin down uh some of these
features alone but there should be more
general principles
now that makes a lot of sense so it
seems as if there's sort of a weaker
claim that
taking these uh principles as more
fundamental than the dynamical laws
provides insight and helps us explain
things and the stronger claim that maybe
there's sort of a maximal set of uh
these principles that we we don't know
yet about you know what can be
constructed what cannot be constructed
that would suffice to pin down the exact
laws of nature
perfectly uh yes quite or rather i would
say explain them
um
so so so i i prefer to use that
statement in the sense that it may not
be the case that he spins on one
specific single law in fact my guess is
that as i said um this would at best um
explain the features of a number of
viable dynamical laws that are
compatible with these assignments or
principles
um and of course the you know bold
conjecture is to say well any relevant
feature of those laws
if we note it as physicists in a way
that is a kind of relevant thing that we
want to explain ultimately can be
explained in the in terms of these
statements about what possible and
impossible transformations you have
um
and that's something that may not be
true um and it will become clear in the
future whether it is that's kind of an
interesting question
sure
okay
final question about the solar system
before we move on to other topics just
and this is like the dumbest question
just for clarifying purposes um when i
first heard about constructor theory
it's not that old right it was just a
few years ago um
i guess my question was like
what is the constructor that picks up
the earth and moves it to another point
in its uh orbit but i think from
everything you've said and i've read
subsequently the point is not that there
is a constructor that is making this
happen but that like
by contemplating the set of all
constructors that could do different
things you can figure out how things
happen yeah yes yes exactly so this is a
very nice question
um
when you're thinking in the
well in the traditional way that we all
use when we approach physics uh as you
said the question is okay i see a kind
of change in the
universe somewhere a movement of sorts
and i want to explain this in terms of
some
ultimately some lower motion and some
kind of initial set of conditions for
that law of motion
um
but so in this sense the question of uh
one could say well okay the question in
the case of constructed here is to say
let's identify the constructor that does
this or that that implements this or
that transformation but as you said this
is not the logic
here the logic is
to
state a
kind of constraint about
um
what are the features of the
possible allowed constructors for
this particular motion that i'm
considering and of course if you think
of the orbits and the planets
uh you could think of much better
constructors than just the laws of
physics as they are right because
um you know you could think of having a
robot that corrects
um the trajectory of a given planet
every so often and makes it even closer
to a specific geometry that you desire
and of course this is actually allowed
by
the laws of physics so it's it's a
permitted kind of constructor
it's just we haven't implemented one yet
um we may in the future i don't know
um and so for the moment we just are
stuck with this particular shape of the
solar system which is the one that is
naturally
implemented by the underlying
elementary symmetries of the dynamical
laws we have so they are in a way you
can think of them as the approximate
constructors that are at work there
because they
in a way are unchanged after they have
implemented one rotation of the
given planet around its orbit
but of course there are better
constructors for the task of letting a
given planet move around a specific um
orbit
with a given shape and we can think of
ways in which in principle
these constructors could be allowed and
could be built but that's not what you
see in the conservation law the
conservation law just says well out of
all these constructors you might think
to implement this transformation surely
you can't use those that violate this
particular thing and they create say
okay given quantity out of something
that doesn't have that
good all right i will let you i will let
you uh
go for the solar system now i think i
understand it a lot better but and i
want to give you an opportunity to um
talk a little bit about because we are
shifting
viewpoint right i mean that's a big um
aspect of this whole program uh
well sorry it seems to me right now that
in the current state of the program a
shift of viewpoint is the more obvious
thing than a particular new view on the
theory of everything or anything like
that and part of that viewpoint shift is
this emphasis on counterfactuals i mean
your book is is literally called the the
the science of kevin kane what is the
title of your book yeah that's right
yeah the science can encounter
the science of canon can't so what is
the role the counterfactuals play
because in some trivial sense anytime
you have a law of physics there are
counterfactuals implicit there because
the law of physics says here are things
that can happen and there are things
that can't the things that can't happen
obey the laws of physics and and those
other things can't but you are putting a
slightly different spin on it i think
yes um so
the
term counterfactual is used um
in the book in a very specific way
so it's
really referring to these statements
that i already mentioned earlier um
the statements about
what transformations are say possible or
impossible or on a given system in the
sense that we we discussed a bit earlier
so in this sense it's a kind of perhaps
narrower sense than say what you find in
mathematics or philosophy um
but it's in in common with those other
notions it has the fact that
these statements are
more general than a particular statement
that you make when you say well i have
these particular dynamical laws in the
describe the universe and these are the
boundary conditions and this is what
happens in the universe and that's all
there is to it
so the
this could be
regarded as a um
in a way a kind of
caricature version of the traditional
way of formulating physics
um but ultimately i think
i would say
this is the ultimate goal of the
traditional physics program in a way
that
we are all hoping um
as physicists let's say that we will
find you know this this um ultimate
dynamical law and this ultimate theory
of the initial conditions and this will
tell us everything we want to know about
what's going on in the universe
and the idea here is to say that
um
this specific statement the one that
fixes the dynamical laws and the initial
conditions
is really just a statement about what
happens in a given universe
um so it cuts out all of the other
counterfactuals because you know they're
not happening so they are um other
possibilities that haven't been realized
and therefore they're not of interest in
a sense
and here we're saying something
different so we're trying to say that
first
that statement in itself wouldn't
exhaust
all the
explanatory things that you can say
about the universe
for example
uh it would miss
um on miss out for example on these
conservation law statements that we
mentioned earlier because
of course in a given universe
you may not
find a particular perpetual motion
machine
but that doesn't mean that it's not
allowed so you know it doesn't happen
but
you know whether it's allowed or not
with different perhaps initial
conditions or different dynamical laws
we wouldn't know
whereas the law that says that isn't
allowed that's not possible
and there is an explanation for why that
is
rules out
all such counterfactual worlds
and leaves us with a set of other
possible uh wells that are kind of um in
principle permitted
so
i think the
the term the emphasis on counterfactuals
is is kind of to say that
among the things that we need to appeal
to in order to explain
particular features of objects that we
encounter in the universe
are
these counterfactual features and
just like with all laws of physics they
appeal to things that are not directly
observable
in the sense that you know the
explanatory part of uh you know quantum
stereo generativity
is far from what we directly see
but nonetheless is the best part of the
explanatory
set of statements that the theories can
make and likewise in this case the
counter-intuitive fact is to say well a
factual thing
something to do with what happens in the
universe as we can
observe it
is actually due to these um
counterfactual principles
and so in that sense it's like adding
or emphasizing let's say a set of these
unseen things in terms of which we
explain uh what we see
in in a more systematic and general way
than it's been done so far
because in a way counterfactuals have
been used
in thermodynamics uh and in other
branches of physics
in in kind of an informal or implicit
way and now we want to do it in a kind
of proper way
um and also including counter factors
from say information theory and other
branches of what we now think of physics
philosophers obviously you've thought
about counterfactuals quite a bit you
know david lewis had a whole metaphysics
of possible worlds and so forth is is
that work of any used to you or do you
do you read about it or are you just
more uh pragmatic about your
counterfactuals i think um these works
are useful to
understand
uh you know philosophical works are
usually useful to categorize things in a
in a very
proper and uh clear way so in that sense
i think they they are very useful to
that degree
um
and they've been useful for me as far as
um you know you can tell
what kinds of counterfactuals i'm
interested in with this theory versus a
more general sense of counter functions
it could be of interest of the views
within philosophy or mathematics and so
on um i think for the level of
predictions and and kind of statements
that we're making at this stage within
construct theory
we don't necessarily need to appeal to
the subtleties that are um mentioned in
these works but they could be useful in
the future
in general i think i quite
like the
work that some philosophers do
in
uh clarifying some of these categories
that perhaps in physics we are slightly
misusing um and i find it kind of
illuminating sometimes to read about
those things
um i'm not sure i find directly
an application for those yet in what i
do so in a way i'm kind of on the
pragmatic side i would say
but
open to to sort of uh refining my
notions if i need to
it's a good place to be um
i didn't actually know what the answer
was going to be to that question so i
thought i would throw it out there but
um so here's something maybe more up
your alley um
it's very interesting to me and i think
to a lot of people who are
physics-minded who first hear
presentations about constructor theory
that we have
a
standard conventional view of what
fundamental physics is like right
quantum mechanics quantum field theory
even you know a few hundred years ago
maxwell's equations newton's laws
and many of your examples when you talk
about constructor theory are
already at the macroscopic emergent
level right enzymes or thermodynamic
engines or something like that and i get
the impression that you treat these uh
what i would think of as an emergent
level of physics a sort of macroscopic
approximation to what's going on
you know with equal dignity
to the more fundamental things that are
going on is is that
a fair reading or is there something new
and special about the relationship
between these different levels from the
constructor theory point of view yes i
think that's a great question i am
um
it's a very important thing that
i think is already implicit in this work
on the quantum theory of information
um
so
the
divide between what's microscopic and
non-fundamental
and what's considered as
microscopic and fundamental
is
something that well i would say somewhat
blood or at least arbitrary in a way
because
we can for sure tell what's clearly
microscopic and what's clearly
microscopic but then there are all of
these things in between that we you know
it's a bit like question what
constitutes um something that's alive
uh you know clearly a bacterium is um
electron isn't but
there are lots of things in between and
one might put the dividing line in in
various places
and now the laws that we are talking
about in constructor theory
try to capture regularities that are
true
independent of the scale so they would
be true
within say um you know a set of objects
that we would label as microscopic like
a bunch of atoms let's say not
particularly
aggregated in any
specific way
but also
it could be true of
a more
macroscopic object which for example
displays some information theoretic
regularities such as um
a
flag which can instantiate some
bit of information or something like
that and this is not an unusual thing in
the sense that
although i think as you said most
traditional physics uh wouldn't think of
laws of this kind as fundamental
in the case of quantum computing we
already encountered these kind of things
because when we talk about qubit and
what a qubit
does and what are the laws that kind of
underlies behavior and so on um we're
not really worried about which specific
system
um
is embodying i mean embodies the qubit
of course we can think of an electron
spin which is pretty microscopic but
then of course as schrodinger did we
could think of a cat being dead or alive
that
you know if we were able to manipulate a
cat in a quantum mechanical way
the relevant degrees of freedom of it
would also behave according to the laws
of qubits
and so
in that sense the examples i'm referring
to
bring in
possible instances of both microscopic
and macroscopic objects
all of which conform to these general
principles because the principles are
scale independent this is something that
doesn't quite um
so this is maybe an element of novelty
if you like
and the principles are not about
saying what is the most probable
behavior of a given aggregate of atoms
above a certain scale let's say in the
thermodynamic limit
they're really about just stating that
certain transformation is impossible
and then it's up to you in a sense to
work out what this implies for a given
aggregated bottom with a given
specification which could be you know
approximating the behavior of an enzyme
or a heat engine or something else
so in that sense i think it challenges
the idea the approach that we are
pursuing challenges the classic divide
between macroscopic and microscopic and
tries to find these principles that are
not
rooted in either of the uh domains so
it's not just they're not just
macroscopic or microscopic but somehow
they are
valid across scales
and in a sense you know we're hoping
that this unifies our understanding of
objects that we regard as emergent and
objects as we are that we traditionally
regard as uh
fundamental and more elementary yeah i
mean let me let's let's continue on that
vein a little bit because
uh
i am a little bit confused about you
know what is approximate and what is
exact and even if that's a sensible
notion in in some way because you make
some provocative statements about
the arrow of time and irreversibility
and the sort of standard
way of thinking about that by standard i
mean what i wrote in my book about the
arrow of time uh is to say that at the
microscopic level all processes are
reversible the laws of physics do not
tell the difference between forward and
backward in time but at the macroscopic
level when you add in some past initial
condition of low entropy you find that
certain things happen and certain things
don't so the world looks irreversible
i mean a classic example is the carnot
cycle back in the 19th century this is
probably one of the first examples of of
one of what you're thinking of you know
it's just stating that certain things
are impossible uh an engine that has a
certain efficiency is is impossible um
but i take that to be a purely
macroscopic statement and and you're
sort of
shifting the ground underneath our feet
a little bit to to
to
i don't know undo the connection i guess
between
uh in my mind anyway between that kind
of macroscopic statement and the idea
that it's an approximation of uh more
uh exact microscopic statements you're
sort of putting on equal footing is that
fair yes i think this is a
very nice way of of expressing what
we're trying to do
um
okay this is a very interesting
topic
so the first thing i want to say is that
um i see the
statements about irreversibility to do
with say
the second law
and the issue of the error of time as
different or distinct
so in a way what i'm going to say has to
do a lot with irreversibility and less
so with the arrow time which is
something that i see as a separate
problem
um
and so so in regard to irreversibility
and what say the
the second law says the second law of
thermodynamics says
i think i agree with um
with the kind of general view that the
second law of thermodynamics is a law
that
in the current formulations at least
um holds in and just in approximate in
in approximate sense so in a way
uh we know that it holds for certain
systems that we call
macroscopic
uh
what that exactly means
we don't want to go into really because
uh
when you know asked for a specific
characterization of what are the systems
for which the second law holds
um even philosophers having kind of
quite quite an issue there
so it's very hard to say to pin down
exactly what the
exact boundary of applicability domain
of applicability of the second laws as
we know them
is but let's say we are fairly happy
pragmatically that they work in a
certain case and not in others and then
we take the dynamical laws as the
fundamental things they are reversible
um and then there are some ways in which
we can make an argument
that typically involves uh you know
quite ingenious ideas that were
pioneered by boltzmann and and others
um to connect the general
um the general sort of um statement that
the second laws make
with um the particular dynamical laws
which are not um which are not
irreversible now
this is a general view
and
what
uh what we think
can happen with this uh new kind of
approach in terms of uh counterfactuals
is that
there could be a way
of
um reformulating the second law
in a way that
doesn't
rely on these approximation schemes so
in a sense it's no longer scale
dependent
and
it would be about
certain
transformations being possible in one
direction and not in the reverse
direction
and by this i mean not that the given
dynamical trajectory is allowed in one
direction not in the other otherwise
this would just say that we are thinking
the dynamical laws are irreversible
which isn't what we expect
but i'm saying a transformation is
possible in one direction and not in the
other
which means the constructor if you like
is allowed in one direction not in the
other
and this is a much more um
plausible statement in a sense and if
you think about it it could actually
hold at all scales because
it's not a surprise that if you want to
perform a certain transformation to
arbitrarily high accuracy in one
direction
you can use a given constructor that has
certain features and
operates according to some means but
then if you try to use the same machine
to perform the opposite transformation
it may actually
stop working all together in the sense
that there's no guarantee that a machine
that performs a task in one direction
should actually be able to perform the
transpose task the
reverse task so in this sense um
the
we expect that
by
taking these statements about possibly
impossible as fundamental
you can somehow
see a possible resolution between this
con conflict between like the
laws that are microscopic and
irreversibility as regarding
uh
constructors and their usability in one
direction or another rather than
trajectories dynamical trajectories of
isolated systems not being
reversible which are obviously in
conflict with the understanding of the
microscopic physics that we currently
have at the moment because all of the
dynamical laws we know that are
fundamental are
kind of expected to be time reverse
symmetric so in this sense
we are somehow proposing a third way out
um
from this
notorious clash
so you know
we would like not to use uh statistical
mechanics methods
because this leads to an emergent set of
laws which is somehow only approximate
and not really fundamental i would say
um
but we're still leaving the possibility
open
for the fact that the second law and
like similar laws
could be fundamental and exact
just that they have to be formulated in
terms of these
other statements
and there you can see that there is a
compatibility between those statements
and the fact that the dynamical
trajectories of elementary constituents
of the objects that
obey these general laws are actually
time reversal symmetric
okay um
yeah this sounds this sounds uh
worth trying to do but still a little
aspirational right like we don't have
the full story uh yet played out but i i
do want to give you an opportunity
because i think there are examples
where you have used this um
kind of
way of thinking about things to sort of
be specific and and
make some claims about physics that you
might not otherwise have reached for
example
in the case of hybrid quantum classical
systems and maybe even quantum gravity
and experimental tests is this is this
too dramatic or is that a fair way of
putting it
no i think that's that's um
that's correct and uh it's it's quite
exciting i think it's another
thing that um
um focus on
um so
this is
um
well ties in well with what we said uh
earlier at the start of conversation
about
you know why would you
want to have more general principles i
mean after all
you know you go in the lab you just want
a dynamical law that kind of uh
you know conjecture to describe
something and then maybe a rival law and
then you kind of test them against each
other and that's how we do physics um
now the specific situation that you're
referring to
is this situation where this logic
doesn't seem to work
as straightforwardly as it usually does
and this is the case of systems that
one way or another
have dynamic laws that are either
intractable
or worse they are not even completely
settled in the case of gravity in
interaction with
a probe that is quantum mechanical
uh fits the second scenario so in the
sense that we've got
many
suggested uh proposals to
describe what's going on uh i think this
goes back to uh kind of feynman and
other scientists who already at the time
were wondering about how do we describe
this kind of system
um but we don't really have
a watertight
way of just making predictions in these
domains that are then testable and at
least can help us
rule out
a class of models for gravity so it
would be nice at least from my point of
view as well because i'm
one of those people who expects gravity
to be modified in a way they will become
quantum rather than quantum theory
becoming classical it would be nice to
be able to rule out a class of classical
models for gravity and we we haven't
been able to do this yet in terms of
just an experiment
so in this domain
even though we don't have
specific dynamical models that can
unambiguously work for making
predictions
we can use principles so in the same way
that
we
we can use we we could in the past use
thermodynamic principles to for example
conjecture the existences of new
particles that were not known yet and so
on
here too
we can appeal to these general
principles that are about
counterfactuals and specifically about
information
um which is one of the
works i've been developing also with
david and others
to
set up a kind of witness
for
testing whether a given system is
classical or not
now this is a very um binary choice so
we're not really
trying to say what is the dynamical law
that gravity um obeys that's not the
kind of question we're asking we're
asking much much
more modest question which is
can we just say if gravity has some
non-classical elements so something that
makes it completely impossible for a
classical theory
one that doesn't have um a multiverse in
a sense
two uh quantum multiverse in
to to describe um this object to
describe gravity not just gravity it
could be any object but gravity is the
most exciting application i would say
and with these general principles um you
can set up a theorem kind of a
theoretical argument that says that
if you can use gravity
to
generate
entanglement between two quantum masses
in some experiment you know some kind of
laboratory setting
and you can rule out other forces other
means of interaction between these two
masses
then gravity has to be non-classical
and note that while this is um in a way
obvious and trivial within quantum
theory because if you have three systems
and you can use one of them to inco
tangle the other two then um in a way
it's a kind of obvious consequence of
quantum inferior information to say that
this system that you use to entangle the
other two should be quantum
in the case where you cannot assume that
this mediator
is uh obeys a given dynamical law this
statement is non-trivial at all and it's
very um it's very interesting that you
can still make this very strong
statement
by just assuming that this system in um
that mediates the entanglement obeys
these general principles and this is
something that i developed with blood
cohadro
we were both really excited that you
could make this general claim
because also it reminded us a bit of
this
of the generality that you have in these
theorems like bell's theorem in quantum
information where you know you can use
this theorem to just rule out
if certain correlations are observed on
given systems a whole class of uh
dynamical models for a quantum system so
sorry for the system in question so you
can rule out the
local hidden variable models
um and likewise in this case
if you can set up an experiment where
you're really sure and this is hard but
you know in principle
where you are you can you can uh argue
that the only
mediator is gravity between these two
masses and they become entangled through
it no matter what dynamical law
specifically you want to use in order to
describe this mediator
then you can rule out
a whole class of
classical theories for it
which obey these general principles one
being locality
in the sense of the locality of quantum
field here if you like and the other one
being the interoperability of
information which is
this constructor theoretical information
principle
that somewhat captures the
some intuitive properties of of
information like systems that we expect
to be true of bits and and similar
systems so that's quite exciting and i
think it's one of the it's kind of maybe
the first example of a theorem that kind
of goes beyond quantum information in a
genuine way
um so it's sort of fulfilling this um
expectation that i was mentioning
earlier that we've been asked to have
this general set of theorems that are
actually
more general the quantum information
theory in the sense they don't assume
quantum theory specifically or any other
dynamical theory
just these general principles
good so let me i i think i actually
understood everything you just said but
just to check let me try to say it back
and you can tell me whether i got it i
mean there's a long-standing worry about
quantizing gravity we haven't been able
to do it right people don't understand
the full theory of quantum gravity and
so some people have said well maybe it's
because gravity still is classical while
everything else is quantum
and one of the problems with testing
that proposal experimentally is that
nobody knows what it means like no one
has a theory really where gravity is
classical and everything else is quantum
so what you're saying is that even in
the absence of a specific theory of
classical gravity quantum everything
else you can still test the idea based
on these general principles and and
again in principle even if in practice
it's very hard you've actually proposed
a setup in which it could be done yes
exactly and i think that's the
you emphasize the right things um
that it's precisely because there is
such uh skepticism about the fact that
you know the the laws that can describe
gravity
must be quantum or
classical that it's important that we
don't make any commitment to a specific
dynamical model to make a prediction um
or at least make this general statement
then of course to make a specific
prediction about the
particular masses that you need in such
an experiment and so on you can use a
number of models but you would like your
conclusions that you you know by
observing entanglement you are
witnessing some known non-classical
effects in gravity to be
as um
kind of independent of these specific
assumptions as possible and i think we
got um
quite far in terms of how general these
principles are because locality is a
pretty general principle
um
and swayed by both quantum theory and by
uh general relativity and other theories
that we might expect plausibly to
describe nature and then the
interoperability of information is
really obeyed by any theory that allows
for observables and
we truly want uh theory to be uh
testable to allow for observables so in
a sense that's kind of also a general
kind of principle
uh that we hold quite there
and you were honest about this but just
in case uh people didn't catch it the
particular experiment that you're
proposing you're not necessarily saying
is feasible in the short term but it's a
in principle thing that maybe some
clever experimentalist can figure out a
better way to do something analogous to
it yes i think so um
this is
so this is about the particular
realization of this experiment
um there have been a number of proposals
um in addition two hours there's this
proposal was put forward by scott dubose
and his team in london
um and now a number of others are being
you know investigated so in that sense
it's a non-trivial um enterprise and in
a way it's uh exciting for that reason
so the experimentalists are kind of now
taking it
um
seriously and and really trying to think
hard of ways in which this could be
brought into
being feasible
but the
the encouraging thing is which was also
something that excited uh people in the
quantum gravity community
is that the masses that you need for
this kind of to display this
entanglement
are
smaller than planck's mass
which is the usual
scale at which we expect quantum effects
in gravity to become
relevant
and so in a way that was a surprise uh
so it's it's uh
10 to minus 12 kilograms which is
a bit smaller than planck's mass not
that small but still quite close to the
current threshold
of you know what's the size of objects
that we can put in quantum
superpositions so in in a sense
uh it's tantalizing and i think um you
know
this might require a long-term effort
but it's it's
somewhat within reach and that's very
exciting to me
yeah no absolutely i'm like
a big believer in trying to figure out
what is possible when it comes to
quantum gravity in principle first
experimentally but any kind of
experiments that we can even contemplate
are worth taking seriously and trying to
improve and then in one i want to ask
about one other uh domain of application
to these ideas which is more macroscopic
uh the this thermodynamics and
information and work extraction story uh
this is one i'm very interested in but
yeah the idea that there are
fluctuations on the microscopic scale
and somehow
um i don't think we've talked about it
in detail on the podcast uh and maybe
this is not the place to get into it but
there's a set of claims going back to
maxwell's demon that you can sort of
interchange information for work for you
know extracting energy from a system or
for doing something useful and i
apologize for not having a better
understanding of what you've said about
this but i mean i have the vague
impression that uh constructive theory
is relevant here somehow yes um
so
this is um
related to this generalization of the
second law that i mentioned earlier
so the
the general statement that's usually
made when talking about the connection
between information theory and
thermodynamics
is as you said through
the idea of maxwell's demon or
more recently
silad engine and the work by bennett and
londawer
so the idea would be that
when
you want to delete or erase information
there has to be some fundamental
thermodynamic cost
to that task
because which is a logically reversible
task because you want to send all
possible states into one blank state
and this particular step is actually
fundamental
in creating a thermodynamic cycle within
things like the maxwell's demon setup or
the cylinder engine set up and so
somehow um it was conjectured by
landauer and then more more
accurately proven by bennett
that there is indeed an irreducible
thermodynamic cost to the task of
erasing
a bit
now this goes through
it's a connection that somehow
implies
the
number of assumptions and these
assumptions could be spelt out in
various ways
and
now there is a
sense in which
on the one hand
if you describe everything in a
completely reversible way so if you have
a fully detailed dynamical model of um
the silhouette engine or of maxwell's
daemon
um then this statement
of course if the dynamical laws are time
reverse symmetric which usually are
as far as quantum c is concerned
and you're not adding any other
irreversibility
then the statement almost follows
from the
from the simple fact that the laws are
time reversal symmetric so in that sense
when you're not putting heat anywhere uh
by hand in this when you make an account
or what's going on in these kind of
cycles
then perhaps you don't need to appeal to
landauer's principle to to claim that
this connection between erasure and
irreversibility is like an additional
principle on top of whatever else we
have
and at the same time if you then assume
that you are in a macroscopic domain
where
there is
some fuzziness about you know your
knowledge of the dynamical laws and you
have some heat source
at any point during this cycle in the
silhouette engine
then
you just apply the second law and it
seems like you can obtain the same
conclusion as landauer's principle so in
a way
although this idea of connecting
information theory and thermodynamic has
been discussed a lot there's still a lot
of controversy there about how
fundamental it is and whether it's even
useful because you know if we know the
dynamics we don't need it and if we know
the second law and we think it applies
we also don't need it now in the case of
this work that i've been
doing
you can connect
information here in thermodynamics in a
different way
and it remains to be understood whether
this other way that landauer and bennett
were proposing could somehow be derived
or understood in terms of this other way
that i'm suggesting so it's kind of an
interesting open question
so the way that i'm
suggesting there is a connection is that
if you define
a
task which is to
extract thermodynamic work out of a
given system prepared in a number of
possible states
uh so you know you've got like um
uh then a flywheel and it's got
different possible dynamical states and
these are your possible states out of
which you want to extract work
or alternatively you've got an atom with
different energy levels and you want to
extract work out of those
or more generally a different system
that we
don't have to specify necessarily then
you can prove by using these general
principles of constructor theory
um an interesting
uh statement which is that these states
out of which you can extract work
must be
perfectly distinguishable
so um distinguishable in the sense of
single shot distinguishability of
quantum theory so they must be for those
who um like uh quantum jargon they must
be orthogonal
or orthogonal subspaces or or things
like that and this has to do with the
fact that when you talk about work
extraction in the way that i'm
envisaging here you're thinking of the
work extraction to happen reliably so
there's a key element in the proof which
is that
uh you're thinking that the task of
extracting work out of these possible
set of states of a given system is
actually possible which means that there
is a constructor which can be presented
repeatedly with the substrate and do
this task reliably
and so there is an interesting
connection between
a set of states that you can use to
perform
what
informally is called useful work in
thermodynamics
and a set of states that you can
distinguish perfectly so any set of
states that you can extract work from
in this deterministic reliable way must
also be a set of distinguishable states
and that's um
so that's a novel connection
and it's interesting that it doesn't uh
to prove these results you don't have to
appeal to any
entropy like consideration or
any scale related considerations so your
seems like this statement is um
three of the problems let's say that the
other connection between information and
thermodynamics
has
um and perhaps as i said it would be
interesting to investigate whether the
second law connection could be somehow
routed into this other connection
and this is an open problem which i'm
kind of thinking about right now so it's
kind of exciting well we like open
problems we like being able to inspire
the young kids in the audience to uh
take all of their uh physics uh and and
not just physics but all of their
academic projects uh inspired by the
mindscape podcast um
but
and the other thing the other reason why
i like this um whole connection one of
the reasons why i like this whole
connection between thermodynamics and
information theory and work extraction
is that
there are at least
claims or hopes that something like this
happens in living cells right in living
beings like there's many attempts
including recent podcasts i've done uh
to link physics principles to how life
works and this might be an example is
that is that too
crazy or are you on that train also no
this is not um
crazy at all at least you know from my
point of view um that
this um
well this this was i think the
original motivation of um
for neumann's so the
so the the view of of you know
envisioning a theory of universal
constructors or more special purpose
constructors was indeed to
define a set of principles that
in the same way as thermodynamic
principles
can
set limitations to thermal engines
could also set limitations to
biological systems uh so and explain to
us
what
both
natural selection and artificial
selection can do
when um you know
exploring the possibilities of organisms
that are fit for a specific environment
and and so we don't have a theory of
that kind yet
and it's a shame i think because um
the
there is a lot of
physics in physics assumptions and
physics considerations to be made
within the
theoretical biology studies that
we've been you know as a scientific
community in general
um advancing so far
um and
in a way this is i would say it's the
next step to
merge together the theory of information
as we know it
quantum and classical with the theory of
thermodynamics
would be like the next step in this
program of building an overarching
general theory for for biological
entities which you can regard in the
most general ways programmable machines
that you know happen to have been
produced by natural selection
but of course the forms of things that
we see in the in a given biosphere
right now are no by by no means
exhaustive of what can be done
and so the question is um
it would be very
uh very very important for technological
developments to have
a set of uh principles that
can tell us exactly what are the
limitations for you know machines that
we might be able to synthesize
artificially and so this kind of goes
into the direction of artificial life
and and all of these other things that
uh are very interesting and although
they're not my
direct concern
i i'm hoping that some of these
principles that we are conjecturing now
could be used uh for for kind of a scope
of this kind
which was ultimately what phenomenon and
visa so i'm hoping that
he'd be happy if he could see this well
i'm glad you're not being too ambitious
just trying to understand quantum
gravity and the origin of life you know
it's something to keep ourselves busy
during our
off hours
now this is great i think that you know
it's it's wonderful to um when we're
faced with these big problems sometimes
you solve them just by being
just by persevering right just by
putting your nose down and moving
forward step by step but sometimes you
solve them by like trying to take a big
leap sideways and looking at things from
a very different angle and and maybe
some new insights come out of that and
you have to try it you don't know it
until you give it a shot
yes and on this note i think um
although some of these problems we
mentioned uh
i mean they do sound as being very
different from each other and perhaps
going in different directions
there is a sense in which the way i see
them they all stem from the same
um perhaps misconception or or
deficiency of the current way in which
we look at things so in a way it's one
example if this thing that we're doing
succeeds
of uh finding how there is a common
route to a number of problems that
appear different
and once you shift as you said the
perspective
the logic of the solution is always the
same it just happens to be
applied in different subfields
and it's not the first time that this
has happened i think
again i mean the quantum theory
computation is always my reference
because that's kind of the thing i know
best
it's
true that
methods of proof within the quantum
theory computation
often
refer to
this universality of cubits so you know
you have very different systems maybe
one is the many body system in condensed
matter physics there's a different
system which involves photons and so on
but once you reduce all of these
different systems into a system of
qubits you can then solve the problem
there and then imply you know this is
very far-reaching implications for all
these different fields and you may not
even know about the details of those
fields but you can still make
statements that are useful and and uh
quite far-reaching and i think in this
case we are
noticing a similar pattern here uh and
so counterfactuals are helping us in a
way in identifying commonalities between
open problems and hoping
to solve them in in a way of just by by
switching to this different mode of
looking at things well i think that's an
inspirational place uh to end up the
conversation with uh you know the
prospects of really making progress on
some big problems so kiara marletto
thanks so much for being on the
wineskate podcast
yeah thank you so much for having me
[Music]
you